veterans at three college campuses just
finished a week-long academic boot camp
programs in Michigan Texas and
Massachusetts were the last of more than
a dozen that took place this summer the
warrior scholar project prepares
veterans to go back to school
Jen Crawford spent a day with
participants at Amherst College she is
now outside Georgetown University
another the campuses in the program Jan
good morning well good morning charlie
you know Georgetown hosted the warrior
scholar project earlier this summer it
is a free program that gives veterans
kind of a sneak peek at life inside the
nation's top colleges you know they live
on campus they go to the cafeteria they
meet with professors it's all teaching
them how to translate that military
background into a classroom classes
start at zero 800 on the campus of
Amherst College for these highly trained
soldiers sailors and Marines now hoping
to become elite students this week's
obviously rough their guide for the week
is Joshua buck a former Army sniper and
drill sergeant now drilling a different
kind of lesson we teach three things
it's critical reading critical writing
and then you know D greening or
adjusting you change yes that's what we
call it you know taking the uniform off
washing the camo paint off for the past
two summers buck has been on the
frontlines of the warrior scholar
project helping veterans move from the
battlefield to the classroom these men
and women are not trained for college so
that's where we come in where a boot
camp the military put a boot we are in
academic boot camp Sid Ellington is a
former Navy SEAL and the program's
executive director it gives them that
immersive sort of experience and once
they've been through that now they're a
whole lot more confident just like a
soldier or a sailor is more confident
coming out of boot camp it might sound
strange that experienced veterans would
need a confidence boost
but as former Navy corpsman Barry
Frederick points out being a student is
different than being in uniform many of
us getting out of military that's that
was a big chunk of our lives so we lose
that part that our sense of being part
of something so we go to school we
become part of something else
it's completely foreign in a way in a
way yes the government spends 12 billion
dollars a year helping veterans pay for
college through the GI Bill but
currently 40% of that goes to for-profit
colleges post 9-11 veterans barely make
up 1% of the nation's elite colleges and
universities ambers professor Jeffrey
Sanborn spent time with the perspective
students he says colleges like his need
more veterans on campus their military
background is like a source of strength
in this context you know it's not
something that you have to kind of like
check at the door the program encourages
vets like 21 year old Tracey Santos to
consider community college with an eye
on eventually transferring to a top
school after first learning how to be a
student again I think the scariest part
is that these people that I am now
surrounded by have come from school it's
like I've been out of school for four
and a half years and it's like starting
over
Santos joined the Marines right after
high school she says one key to the
program is it's taught by veterans they
know exactly how to talk to you and they
put what you've done before in the
service to what you can be doing now
bucks spent 11 years in the Army
including three tours in Iraq and went
through the warrior Scholar Program
himself in 2015 now he uses his personal
story to remind the students of what's
important I have eight friends tattooed
on my arm that have died but only three
of them actually died in combat the
other five went out due to demons in
their own head five new friends yeah and
there's actually more than that now
fueled by that loss buck is working
toward medical school where he hopes to
become a psychiatrist to help more
veterans with the transition home it's
personal for you too
it seems like this program is also
personal for you yeah because every one
of these vets whether I just met him
this week or I haven't met him yet you
know I consider them family
now with nearly 200,000 service members
leaving the military every year schools
like Georgetown are actively trying to
recruit more veterans and with that in
mind the warrior Scholars project is
looking to expand it is totally funded
by private donations as the president
man first college told us when we were
up there last week it's important it's
this program is for veterans the
benefits that it gives to colleges
having veterans on campus is even
greater Nora that's a really good point
Jan what a great story you know every
day we heard another story that mount
that suggests the appreciation and
respect for the American military yep I
would agree just something as simple I
was on a plane yesterday and they say
we'd like to welcome the veterans first
and anybody in military uniform and it
makes you proud to say right this way
that story you're right is another
example how important it is and when I
respect one said you know you can judge
a nation's values by how they treat
their veterans and their most vulnerable
there's a good example that we're trying
to take care of our veterans thank you
Jan for that story